et dans cette suite maintenant on va
parler d'un projet humanitaire et d'un
projet étudiant avec deux étudiantes
vous êtes en master management qualité
et est conduite d'affaires l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin bonsoir anne
les bons soirs à rima là vous êtes 2
mais en fait plutôt un groupe de six
pieds pas si vous êtes si l'étudiant
tout il ya des étudiants dans votre
projet vous êtes un groupe de six
étudiants en master est avec vous et on
va évoquer effectivement un projet
humanitaire qui s'appelle up child la
destination dead d'enfants handicapés
d'un centre de bailly et dans ce cadre
là vous avez raison plusieurs opérations
de sensibilisation qui se termine sa
durée depuis le début de l'année
étudiante depuis le mois de septembre et
là ça se termine notamment par une
exposition photo qui se déroule en ce
moment à la bibliothèque universitaire
la revente parler de cette exposition un
mot sur ce sur ce projet alien
comment est née à ou alors il est temps
que hossein donc dans notre master on
doit faire des projets d conduite de
projets de pour pour apprendre la
gestion de projet et nous en fait on a
choisi de travailler sur dans
l'humanitaire et dans l'humanitaire
parce que c'est vrai que quand on voit
votre master management de qualité
conduite d'affaires ça fait pas
forcément pensé à but humanitaire
le premier but c'est la conduite d'un
projet du début à la fin
mais après chacun de soyeuses choisi son
domaine et nous en fait tous les six ont
été touchés par un l'humanitaire par les
enfants et par le handicap des enfants
surtout comment ça fait le lien avec le
centre de bailly et comment cette femme
travaille avec 60 on a fait tout d'abord
différentes recherches d'associations
donc
et ça aboutit vers l'association sports
et loisirs
donc on a fait un partenariat avec eux
donc à la base c'était soit on faisait
au conduit à ce projet tout seul soit on
fait un partenariat avec une association
a préféré faire ce partenariat avec une
association pour avoir plus de poids et
de valeurs et nous qu'on a fait ce
partenariat avec l'association de sports
et loisirs qui qui
qu'ils aient un lien avec le centre de
bayod exemple entre deux balises 500
criquets n'accueille que des enfants en
situation de handicap
oui tout à fait d'accord ces centres est
une école en même temps pour enfants en
situation de handicap d'accord quand
vous êtes arrivé chez eux vous est
stocké à leur porte et devait être
surpris donc oui ils ont pas l'habitude
de voir de nouvelles personnes dans leur
centre donc c'est ça a été un peu
préparait déjà à l'avant ce mets salés
alors quelques l accent est mis en place
depuis le début de la rentrée
universitaire en septembre octobre donc
en fait on a mis trois 3 plein en fait
on avait trois axes c'était premièrement
la récolte fin pour pour une cabane dans
le jardin d enfants c'est une cabane
plus gros oui une grande rahman pour
enfants handicapés adapté aux enfants et
donc on avait prévu de mettre un budget
à hauteur de 1000 euros donc c'était
toute l'année des actions de récolte de
fonds à l'université via un site
internet qui s'appelle public âme et
puis à l'université c'était des ventes
de gâteaux de café de couscous un
déjeuner couscous pour récolter les 1000
auront donc qui ont été récoltés et la
cabane est mise en place depuis le 8
juin
donc c'est vraiment la réalisation comme
dj son projet c'est ça on parle d'une
idée et puis on fait toujours en sorte
pour effectifs sabotière bien dans les
délais en plus parce que oui
notre deuxième axe c'était la
sensibilisation donc en fait on a fait
des actions dans une école de versailles
avec des ateliers de sensibilisation
pour enfants valides pour les anciens
les sensibiliser au handicap des enfants
dans une dans un centre de loisirs à
gennevilliers seulement comment les
enfants réagissent alors la
sensibilisation au handicap ils sont ils
sont intéressés c'est pas forcément
quelque chose qui va les toucher parfois
que je me voyais eux non plus pas besoin
casser quelque chose qui ne connaissent
pas ils voient certaines certaines
personnes de leurs familles sont
touchées par le handicap mais c'est pas
quelque chose qui connaissent pas
énormément donc on a vraiment essayé de
les sensibiliser au handicap
donc avec une petite présentation et des
ateliers des ateliers ludiques donc
des types de handicaps c'était plutôt
sensorielle c'est à dire le moteur la
vue donc on les a mis dans un fauteuil
roulant voir s'il pouvait se débrouiller
cissé il avait des difficultés donc ils
se sont vraiment mis dans la peau de
d'enfants handicapés et donc il était
vraiment faim ils ont appris plein de
choses et c'était vraiment très
constructive pour ses enfants
donc là versailles à la fois j'aime vie
mais aussi une expiation ces deux
matières et alors là je disais donc
l'opération en fête se termine avec
cette exposition de photos on va voir
quelques images
actuellement la bibliothèque
universitaire jusqu'au 1er juillet alors
là aussi c'est une action de solidarité
ces décrets sensibilisation aussi donc
on essaie vraiment sensibiliser le grand
public au handicap et de se dire que la
particularité vous l'avez pas dit non
mais c'est que le photographe qui a fait
les photos est en situation de handicap
ou repos d'hier cgt manuel lui ces mêmes
emmanuel mouret qui fait partie d'une
association qui s'appelle égard qui qui
milite pour l'égalité dollar entre entre
handicapés et valides et donc c'est
effectivement un handicap et qu'elle a
fait l'exposition qui s'abaisse
transurbain d'accord il y avait le but
de l'exposition qu'est ce qu'on peut
voir la vue quelques donc il faut savoir
que
l'art n'est pas une barrière enfin un
handicap n'est pas une barrière à l'art
et c'est vraiment ce thème là qu'on a
voulu mettre en exposition et donc cet
artiste expose des photographies en noir
et blanc
donc vous pouvez voir les images donc à
l'université donc cette exposition est
mise en place depuis le le ced le 1er
juin et jusqu'au 7 juillet donc c'est
encore quelques jours pour voir
l'exposition hameau peut-être sol
l'association égale art égard
en fait c'est une association qui milite
justement pour pour que les personnes
handicapées qui ont des compétences dans
la photographie autres puissent avoir
accès à l'art comme toute personne
valide et donc emmanuel m'en réfère en
fait partie et il faut savoir aussi que
ces photos ont déjà existé en couleur et
que là il les expose en or blanc moi ça
va pas donner dans la même impression
certains magasins et blanc ou en couleur
c'était votre dernière action salle
exposition de photos quel bilan vous
vous tirez alors cette année de
solidarité ben c'est une année très
riche
et puis il faut savoir que au sein de
notre master management de qualité et
conduite d'un faire c'est un master très
très très très riche et puis très très
dense c'est une année très difficile
très riche et puis très enrichissante
mais qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que ça
peut vous apporter dans par exemple la
suite de votre vie professionnelle
puisque pour améliorer vous serez plutôt
responsable des achats responsables des
conduites d'affaires et ses parts dans
les entreprises manager qu'est ce que
votre avis 24 ça peut apporter de c'est
vraiment la conduite d'un projet du
début à la fin et donc dans tous ses
aspects dans l'indre le dans la gestion
de deux tweets donc voilà la finance si
c'est l'atteinte des objectifs
oui je sais qu'on a à la plage du
management de projet c'est entre ce
qu'on a fixés au début en septembre et
ce qu'on a en octobre quand on aura fini
on aura atteint tous nos objectifs ce
qui est vrai on aura appris beaucoup de
choses simples et sa demande qu'est ce
qui va se passer justement en octobre
est-ce que vous passer le relais un
autre groupe d'étudiants ou est-ce que
alors je passais tous pour le même
centre de bailly pour un autre centre
mais est-ce que
un passage de relais où effectivement
oui effectivement chaque année en fait
il ya six groupes projets donc il y aura
les prochains les prochaines personnes
qui vont reprendre le projet humanitaire
je ne sais pas s'ils vont travailler
encore avec le centre de bail ou pas ils
ont le choix de choisir un autre centre
s'ils veulent mais il faut savoir que le
centre de bailly de veut bien
retravailler avec notre master parce que
ça s'est super bien ce point d'accord
merci tout cas vous d'être venu et puis
un salut amical évidemment aux quatre
autres étudiants qui composent ce groupe
qui a travaillé donc sur ce projet hope
shine projet de solidarité au sein de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
merci à vous